hello everyone and welcome back to the
Lynn Doris a be rapid to challenge a
game for in the third match ended in a
draw which means we are going into
Armageddon so after a lot of videos and
a lot of games we have reached the final
game and Nakamura chose the color Cindy
Armageddon he chose the black pieces as
he usually does saying that he he deals
better with having last time on the
clock and if some of you I still don't
know what Armageddon is Armageddon is
when a match is a tie in the end then
they have to decide who is the winner
and the player with the white pieces
gets an extra minute most of the times
it's it's an extra minute and he has to
win the game otherwise if the game is a
draw then the player with the black
pieces wins the game ended the match of
course so without further ado let's
check out what happened in the
Armageddon game new book opened with e4
and the nakamora went for e5 and now
comes knife to c3 so after a long time
we get something new the Vienna game we
have Knight to c6 and now g3 the Louis
Paulsen variation a preparing to
fianchetto delights worship with Bishop
to c5 by Nakamura and the now comes the
blush of the g2 we have Knight f6
preparing the castle black can be very
happy with his development here and
night in G to eat you now preparing to
Castle maybe d3 f4 in the future and so
on so the six by black with v3 by dubov
and a six now preparing to further
expand on the Queen side we have castles
by dubov and Bishop to e6 by Nakamura
and this position already has been
reached before several times but it's
interesting that Nakamura had it against
Timothy Maghreb in 2019 in the world
blitz championship were Knights to defy
was played but here do Bach plays h3
against Nakamura so a slow move Nakamura
replies also with a slow move h6 taking
away the g5 Square from White's Bishop
and King to h2 now just improving the
position of the King maybe later on now
you're gonna play a form since you no
longer have to worry about this pin and
as white allowed that Nakamura goes just
the b5 strikes in the center we have eek
a press on d5 Knight captures and now f4
by dubov as it is now possible the King
is no longer on g1
we have a captures on f4 and now Bishop
captures on d5 it's a new move there is
a game where Knight captures on f4 was
played but here Bishop captures on d5 is
the new move by do both and already as a
move 11 we have a completely new game
and now the thing is of course you have
to pick up the your piece you have to
recapture however you first have to play
F captures and g3 would check Nakamura
missed this he played Bishop captures on
d5 first saying that okay of course
White has to capture however Knight
captures on f4 instead and now Nakamura
has some problems his bishop is under
attack and he has to move it there's a
double attack here under bishop and his
king is still in the center of the board
which is very dangerous White has an
open F file the Queen can get into the
game very easily so Nakamura goes ninety
seven hopes the castle on the next move
but Queen h5 by dubov puts pressure on
f7 but also a triple attack on the
bishop now so you again don't have time
to castle you have to defend the bishop
so c6 and now it's only a matter of
removing the defender of the f7 square
so here Knight captures on d5 and there
is there is not much more you can do
here C captures on d5 was played and now
of course well you can even pause the
video and try to find it the best move
for white while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
supporting the well I don't know it's
like a triple attack and for those of
you who just want to enjoy so it's nice
a six point is now the queen is under
attack the bishop is under attack black
cannot capture due to the pin there is
now a double attack on the f7 point from
the Queen and the rook so it's just a
blacks position completely falls apart
here and the problem with g6 is Queen e5
again the Queen is under attack
and also the rook here so a black will
be just completely lost here so nakamora
try the Queen to d6 he said okay I'm
gonna give up the f7 pawn and maybe try
and rush my King over to the Queen side
maybe it's still playable I only need a
draw I don't really need to win this
game however dubab doesn't go for the F
point he goes for the G
pawn with check nakamura moves and now
rook captures on f7 and now blacks
position is just terrible
nakamura went rook 8 f8 wants to get his
rook into the game but now Bishop to f4
do ba finds a nice in-between move to
get his rook into the game and here the
problem is if you you don't have a good
square for the Queen if Queen d6 y can
just capture it the knight is pinned you
cannot move the knight or also if you
try something like Queen to c6 black
just gets made at Queen f5 check the
night still cannot capture so after the
King moves now you have a double attack
on a fade just captures captures
captures with check and this is just
checkmate as the bishop covers this and
this and the night covers this the King
has nowhere to go
so after Bishop f4 Nakamura finds a way
to stay in the game but he needs to give
up the Queen he played rook characters
on f7 and now Bishop captures on d6 a
dubov of course grabs the Queen rook to
f1 with check now the rook is nicely
defended here King to h1 and now Bishop
captures on d6 so look that you want
Lugo brings the rook into the game and
rook H to f8 so Nakamura still has some
counter play to 2 rooks for a queen but
it's much easier to play with the Queen
since the king is on an open board so
queen g4 track King the c6 and now
adjust knight c6 attacking the Rookery
maneuvering the night hoping for a poor
move with the roof so maybe night to d4
check picks up some material however we
have rook to f6 which is a good square
but still tonight the d4 check with King
to b6 and now looked at e2 offering a
trade here
improving the King's safety rook f1
check came to g2 now rook f2 will no
longer be possible and now Knight to c6
Nakamura wants the trade off this Knight
from Knight captures we have B captures
and c3 now so now it's a queen and rook
against the two rooks and the bishop of
course a much much better for white
however nakamura only needs a draw so
perhaps do both will maybe lose some
time maybe he'll just go and get into
time trouble and start making mistakes
so anything had happened so rook one
back to f5 by nakamura and now b4 of
course do Google now start pushing his
pawns on the Queen side King b7
and Queen to g7 chick Nakamura blocks
and just Queen captures on h6 so now you
even have a past h1 which you can use in
the future this for back to c7 and now
Queen back to e3 we rush up to b6
attacking here also may be a freeing up
the EDF to square but just f4 not
worried about this better back to c7 and
now even h4 and this is a beautiful move
for Du Bois because basically he's
saying I don't care about rook g7 I
don't care if you capture on g3 point is
after King history you can even give up
the Queen here and after all the trades
you're up two points with a completely
winning past H bond so not much for
black to look for here so Nakamura tried
a 5 button just a 3 for do both with a 4
Nakamura closes the position but now
Queen to d3 preparing b5 to bust open
the position and hopefully checkmate a
Nakamura skink
so look the f1 and now of course b5
Nakamura can just wait and see what
happens route back to f6 v captures on
c6 with check King captures and then out
Quinta a sex with check with Russia back
to be six but now Queen captures an a4
just gobbling up all of the material
Queen kink back to be 7 and now Quinta
eh preparing rook to e7 check the trade
off at least one pair of rooks so rook
to f8 attacking the Queen but now rook
d7 with check Bishop the c7 and now
Queen to be Phi with check and there's
no and not all that many squares left
for the for the king so look the b6
blocking but now there's a well there
are a lot of ways you can win the screen
captures and if I was winning but Du
Bois goes for the absolute quickest way
rugcutterz and c7 with check and it was
in this position that he Cara Nakamura
resigned the game and Daniel dubov is
the winner of the win Doris ABI rapid
challenge taking first place in in a
well in a really tough competition and
taking a first price of $45,000
so here you resign because after King
captures Quincy 5 check picks up the
rook here and then it's just the Queen
against the rook and you're also up for
pawns which also helps and this is just
unplayable so I have to work a person c7
and nakum
resigned and the dubov is the champion
so there we have it that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and this short
coverage although in the rossabi rapid
challenge now I would like to thank Carl
I Veronica scum Stevie
Dale Bowden Alexandre Cree and Mathis
financial corporation for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video syrup thank you for
watching and I will see you soon not
continuing the coverage as the event is
over but I will check up on your
suggestions to see if there's something
I've missed and then hopefully we will
be able to continue the good stuff
meaning the Paul Morphy saga so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day